[Music]
well I'm you all obviously know of Roger
I wonder how many of you know just how
many fields Roger Penrose has
contributed to I spent my professional
life talking to people who will Nobel
Prizes and the rest but I don't think
I've ever come across someone who has
contributed to so many fields I mean he
worked with Stephen Hawking on
singularities and that led to our
present theories of the the universe
starting from a singularity he's
contributed to our ideas of
consciousness and the limits of logic
and rationality and has also done work
on tiling the infinite plane and a good
guide for if you want to find Rogers
work look for where infinity crops up
and you'll find Roger the little table
nearby working on it Roger
you've always been an extremely visual
scientist when did that start have you
because you you were you knew Asher and
your father knew where did it come from
that or was it some things no well my
father was very artistic
he came well his brother was Roland
Penrose who was well-known in thrillers
I mean he he in with the surrealist
group was one of the founders of the
Institute for content content area arts
and he and those two and their brothers
were all very artistic and their father
was a professional portrait painter
James Doyle Penrose he used to do very
sort of realistic sort of pictures very
religious pictures too right and then
your father became friends with with
Escher didn't he well this that the
story is more complicated see when I was
a graduate student in Cambridge I went
to the International Congress of
mathematicians was being held in
Amsterdam that was in my second year as
a graduate student
and I heard about this exhibition by
this extraordinary artist they'd have an
exhibition there because all the
mathematicians around they thought they
would be interested in Asia and it's one
of the lecturers who I saw the category
is head catalog and you opened up a
picture of the birds flying both ways at
once night and day but there were a lot
of fantastic pictures there and I came
away thinking that I'd like to do
something impossible myself so I finally
I tried to draw pictures with bridges
and railways and roads and things going
in possible ways and I simplifies this
sort to a triangle so there's a triangle
or each two edges meet at right angles
and it's impossible but you can see the
picture of it I didn't know you invented
that I did apart from it having been
invented several years earlier by
somebody else it wasn't quite the same
there's a man called Oscar Wright his
father who was a Swedish artist he
hadn't thing with cubes going around
which basically the same idea you could
trace back the ideas who old pictures
Broyles as I said you've always been
interested infinity or at least it crops
up everywhere in your work and of course
ashes paintings they often they often
start off with a few simple shapes in
the center and then a little bit further
out the same shape but smaller and
there's more of them and then obviously
as you get to the edge if you go magnify
there'd be an infinite number of oh yes
now that that that was stimulated by
somebody else it was a coxeter there was
another mathematician who's well call
him a Canadian I think he was
Scottish originally but anyway he
acquainted Asha with these pictures
circle with the court what are called
circle limits we have angels and devils
and they all get more and more crowded
up to the edge and the edge represents
the infinity of the world that they
inhabit how important is the picture to
your work because for someone like me
who looks at it it seems very why why do
you find pictures useful because lots of
your contemporaries
they're pure mathematics and although
you are a mathematician it's unusual
that you combine math but with pictures
that's how every time I've been to see
you and I can't understand which is most
of the time sitar and the starts of draw
a picture at which point I still don't
understand but at least there's a
picture when you see what when I went to
University College as an undergraduate
and I was expecting when I went there I
find people who think like me you see
because I could I was perhaps more
mathematical there were a few other
quite good mathematical people at school
but I thought you know okay they'll all
be like me you see well I didn't expect
to find so many different ways of
thinking about mathematics and one of
the biggest divisions is whether you
like to think visually or in terms of
equations and they were only about two
of us in the whole class who preferred
to think visually so it's not it's not
so common in mathematics are the best
mathematician to do both you know they
can bacon I wouldn't think the best lot
of the best could think that way but
it's kind of unusual we should when it
came to the exams my best papers were
not the geometry papers my best paper
was in algebra curiously enough because
you see when you do a geometry problem
you have to see how to do it and it's
geometrical and then you were to
translate that into words and you write
down the words and you
to keep flipping back from when we're
thinking to another way of thinking so
my view is that it doesn't really help
in examinations to be a visual thinker
it doesn't help you so much in exams and
so maybe that's a reason that
mathematicians on the whole artist
geometrical as you might think kind of
certainly it's a minority of them think
that way one of the other areas that you
worked is a small story that there was a
competition some while ago a company but
how long ago the amongst mathematicians
they decided what what's the minimum
number of shapes that it will record
that a you can tile an infinite floor
with this is how they amused themselves
I think and at one point and I will I
know I'll get the details wrong but I
think it was a Chinese chat had it down
to several thousand shapes with a
student write several thousand shapes he
could prove that you could tile an
infinite space with these this set
number of tiles and the pattern would
never repeat so it's not like a square
tile and then Roger got involved because
he thought that sounds interesting
would anyone like to guess how many
shapes Roger has got it down to just
shout out and everyone else went all
right it worked its way down I think it
got down to about a hundred by Robert
burger who had the number actually and
then it got down to kept working its way
down to until it got down to six and I
was aware of that six I has another way
of doing it with six you see but when I
heard about that and I was told that the
chap who did this like to find the
smallest number so I said well I can do
it with five because I could glue to my
bits together well it wasn't quite like
that but but then fiddled around and I
got it answer to
and that was the end of that competition
but the enduring thing about it is you
think well that's interesting pastime
but actually this work on on a periodic
tiling has tremendous things to say
about the limits of logic and the way
that consciousness might work and it's
one of the things that's most
interesting like the work is that Roger
goes off in all these different
directions but are you all are you
thinking of this will give me another
Avenue back to this because they your
work has been tremendously varied but
but it does sort of double back to
things that you've always been
preoccupied like the limits of logic I
don't know whether I can answer that
question I don't know I just do what
interests me mainly and the logic thing
I had lots of conversations when I was
an undergraduate with Ian Percival we
used to talk about well a lot of other
things but logic was certainly one of
the things we talked about and I was
very worried by this thing called
girdle's theorem because it seemed to
show that there were things in
mathematics you couldn't prove and then
when I went to Cambridge as a graduate
student and I went to three lecture
courses which were nothing to do with my
actual work well missed by Hermann Bondi
general relativity in cosmology one was
by Paul Dirac famous quantum mechanics
one of the founders of quantum mechanics
and he gave they were both beautiful
sets of lectures in a completely
different way and then I went to another
course which was a course by a man
called Steen on mathematical logic
because I was interested in this gödel
question and I learned about Turing
machines there's a general receipt well
the basis of modern computers if you
like Turing machines and I learned about
girl's theorem and I learnt it's my
relief because it was not that girl
showed that there are things you
couldn't prove it's just that if you had
a particular set of rules that you
follow and that these rules are things
you could put on a computer to check
whether they've done
been done right then those rules you can
find some other example but these are
improve things about numbers you see and
infinite things about numbers such as
for example every number is the sum of
four square numbers it should prove by
LaGrone it's quite a hard theorem or
every even number greater than 2 is the
sum of two prime numbers that's still
improved things of that sort you see
these are statements about the infinite
now the question is you've got certain
rules about how you prove things and if
you fix those rules and if you believe
they only give you truths what girl does
he comes along says well look here's a
statement of just the same kind but you
could see by virtue of understanding
what the statement means that you cannot
prove it using those rules if you trust
those rules to only give you truths so
if you using the rules only give you
true things there's another thing which
you can see is true by virtue of your
knowledge that the rules will have any
beautiful true things but you cannot
prove it using the rules um if that's
twisted logic they so you can you you
can tell it's true by knowing that the
rules only give you truths but you can't
use it prove it using the rules yes I
found that stunning you see yes
absolutely stunning I mean in case
that's puzzling that's the math the deep
mathematical version of this statement
is false yes you all understood it
because you understand the rules of the
English language but you can't decide
whether what I said is true or not yes
it has to be that's not because I didn't
say properly oh that you didn't
understand it properly and that's a
trivial version and what girl really
says this statement is not provable by
those rules
yes but proved it and and is it would
you agree that it basically made him the
most unpopular logician ever well well
I'd say that if you he taught at the
University of Vienna and if you go to
the courtyard the university they're big
huge building and they have a very
proudly a bust in
every single famous professor or every
professor who taught their going back
several centuries
except for Kurt gödel oh that's a big
mistake
yes so no he opened up all sorts of the
opened up huge areas of mathematics no
yes but he does pull the rug out from
under the pretension yes you will have a
formal system yes which once you've got
it will be able to give you the correct
answer to any question you give it which
is the still the founding belief that
we'll be able to create an AI and when
we do it'll give us the answer to
everything
yeah rather clearly said no it won't
with uhm yeah that's where it leaves you
I mean it shows you that's the way it
led me you see yes and that's made you I
don't popular tune people disagree with
me let's actually do well they quit a
few quite a few bought my book the
imprisonment so it can't be just
unpopularity that did well no but I just
spent I spent several months
interviewing the lots and lots of the
the techie boys who are doing the AI
revolution and if I mention your name
they got you yes well that's you see it
does show that there is something
different going on in and this well they
learnt from Steen's course it may not
have been quite how he put it but but
there is something going on in human
understanding which is not computational
it it's different from what a computer
does so okay when people call it
artificial intelligence I think that's a
misnomer
what official cleverness perhaps right
but they C stands for are you know what
an eighteen current so you couldn't say
[Laughter]
how many people would you say I know you
don't like sides in this but let me
agree but look at the fashion has run
against you the fashion is that no no
we're going to build a machine and human
consciousness he is essentially we will
be able to capture it in a digital
machine yeah I think that's just wrong
no I mean you've been Megan what you
said and it's something else more
recently I produced a chess position you
see he which you give it to fritz tuned
that's the best chess computer system
you see and you programming in to be
Grandmaster level and this is a chess
position that you show it to any human
player who who knows anything about the
game at all it's obviously a drawing
game it's a draw but if you give it to
fritz and play against for its it loses
really yeah and I was expecting it's a
Lewis - well not a chess that's that's
my I was the chest dancing my family
some people say oh I could I could
program my computer to do that but of
course that's cheating because you're
using your understanding - well I'm not
sure will it be quite hard to I mean you
can do it - I could probe
even I could program the computers to do
the right thing in this position but
then you see changing doesn't this
position you see that's what I mean he
could program it to get the right answer
for that position sure but then when you
say is there something going on in human
consciousness which is non computation
it's quite an innocent sounding sentence
really but what would you what word
would you reach for to describe the
thing which is not computational would
you reach or something like intuition or
inspiration understanding
but an understanding that you didn't get
through by steps of logic
yeah because even that's not
understanding you're just following the
rules see if you simply follow the rules
you've been given you can do that
without any understanding the
understanding is why the rules work and
that's something different like and
that's why I say the girdle thing shows
you that if you know why these steps
will give you only truths if you've gone
through that that level of understanding
allows you to transcend those rules
themselves yes and that's something that
that that girdle and you and someone
like Greg cheetahmen have all said the
computer once you've given it the rules
like the rules that they put into deep
mind or the you know the the program
that beat Garry Kasparov it can
laborious lis explore all permutations
of that rules but it can't jump outside
the rules and you are saying the human
mind you can but not by having another
rule that steps behind it
to say of now and again jump out of
these rules because then be trapped in
that larger set of rules you'd still be
trapped and the interesting thing about
about girdle is he spent the last 20
years of his life trying to prove
intuition and slowly start themself to
death he went bonkers but but there's a
rather interesting thing isn't it to
want to prove that you can the intuition
the lies outside of proof you could get
a long way with not understanding no but
you asked me what do I think it is you
see that leads into another root you see
I mean this was the sort of reasoning
that I was using I mean you know I'm
being although I was brought up in this
Quaker family as we were discussing
earlier I didn't have any religious
beliefs and so that even though I think
there's something going on on our heads
which transcends understanding and
therefore it's not a computer and the
only sense of the word
what could it be because we know that
the laws of physics I think we've had a
wonderful example of that recently with
these gravitational waves coming from
black holes spiraling into each other
which this LIGO detector they can tell
because of enormous calculations that
people have done on Einstein's theory
they know exactly what form these waves
should be and so they therefore you can
tell when the detector is actually
received waves of that type so this is
an example which shows you how how
powerful you can imitate nature powerful
you can imitate nature in this subject
of Einstein's general relativity no you
should ask myself okay what else
well there's quantum mechanics you see
now quantum mechanics it consists of two
parts you see this is basically I
learned from Dirac about the puzzles of
quantum mechanics I think it was partly
because I dozed off at the beginning
wasn't it clear my mind wanders a
certain point this is his very first
lecture oh you see it was right at the
beginning and he was talking about the
superposition principle they see if you
have a particle and if this one state of
the particles it's here another state of
the particles it's here then you can
have States works here and here at the
same time so you can see particles can
be in two places at once
crazy but that's how quantum mechanics
works then he took a piece of chalk and
I think he broke it in two and said look
the chalk is now imagined it's here and
here at the same time this was the point
my mind wandered you see because he gave
some explanation I think sort of
I think the faintest idea what it was I
just remembered something about the word
energy coming into it and I'm worried
about that ever since you see so why is
it that you don't have pieces of chalk
and in two places at once
people in two places at once and all
that and this is a big problem in
quantum mechanics so my view was that
quantum mechanics can't be quite right
and Einstein had that view yes this is a
little bit more specific because it has
to do with why is it not right but that
took me longer to think about that but
the view is that it can't be quite right
and the way in which it's not quite
right has to be taken advantage of by
the brain so this was the idea that I
had and I wrote this book the emperor's
new mind I thought probably it would
disappear without trace but then Stephen
Hawking had written his book on the
brief history of time and he had got
what's his name Carl Sagan who writer
before which so I thought actually gets
done buddy decent to write a foreword
then maybe so I got Martin Gardner so I
I had no idea what Martin Martin
Gardner's views when he said yes I agree
with you he says so he was happy to
write forward and then I thought well
it's probably won't disappear without
trace you know the difference between
the two books is that brief history of
time the Hawking's about that big and
Rogers handy-dandy quick primer for
consciousness about Pathak it's got
pictures yes
but it's interesting is this - lot of
people hated it yes they did
oh gosh that I was making a series on
consciousness at the time and again my
whole life has been mentioning you and
people going like this yeah because they
the criticism was that all rogers has
done is taken a mystery and wrapped it
in enigma and said there you go taking
two things we didn't understand and say
because we don't understand these two
things they must be the same thing
that's not the argument at all they had
read the book No
that's true it's true but the thing is
you see I had no idea what the answer
was
so I wrote the book thinking that by the
time I had to learn some neurophysiology
and that sort of thing by the time I'd
love that bit I would see where there
could be something going on in the brain
see the argument had to be that it had
to be some effect where gravity comes in
and I had no idea at that time it didn't
seem to be no propagation had any chance
of being the answer and the thing is you
see I was hoping that this book would be
read by young people trying to learn
about science and so on most of the
letters I got from people from old
retired people and those were the people
who had time to read the book I guess
but anyway not just old retired people
one person who did read the book was
Stuart Hameroff yes in Stuart Hameroff
his day job is to put people and maybe
in the night to and it put people to
sleep reversibly in other words give
them general general anesthetics when
they have operations and unlike most of
his colleagues who were just as capable
of putting people to sleep and waking
them up afterwards they didn't seem to
worry as much as he did about what they
were actually doing yeah so this point
was what to be general as an aesthetics
act on and his view was that they act on
these things called microtubules and so
he sent me a letter and you said I think
missing from your argument is you
haven't mentioned microtubules and I
thought microtubules I get lots of
letters from lots nutty people you say
oh gosh it's another one but then I
looked it up and I saw the yeah they're
real I should know I should have learned
about them and these are little tiny
tubes and I thought the charts of
preserving quantum coherence that level
was much much greater than in just the
last year or two a lot more people are
coming round to this idea because the
problem was always people said but can
you maintain quantum states in the brain
because the brain is a noisy messy and
warm place which is generally not good
for contact generally if we want to do
anything with quantum mechanics we we
buy a truckload of liquid nitrogen and
freeze the entire place down and then we
start
we they and some people didn't like it
but in the last two years a lot of new
people are starting because they've
realized actually they can find
different quantum stuff in the brain
where they didn't expect it so so Rogers
detractors are all feeling bit peeved at
the moment but are you a duelist and the
reason is because Roger has often said
there's the physical universe but I
think ideas and mathematics exist in
their own dimension now I may be saying
this wrongly but if that is true that is
dualism that's what that's what ever
since Descartes you were not allowed to
talk about something in the material
universe not not supernatural Lucy John
Searle used to accused me of being a
trial it's three worlds you see it with
the three words you speak one world I'd
like to put at the top is the world of
platonic ideas specifically mathematics
which exists independently of us and
after all since the universe was running
along quite happily before there were
people the laws of physics were there
long time there were people and so the
mathematics which governs those laws was
there quite independently people so
that's the Platonic mathematical world
which has its own existence has its own
existence yeah and then the physical
world is controlled by a small part of
the mathematical world and then when the
physical world is in the right sort of
construction like human brains or brains
of other animals well I don't know how
far down it goes it's certainly not just
humans I would think that when that's
organized correctly then mentality comes
out of it's in a sense so it's as the
each comes out of the other but then
there's a sort of triangle which is the
kind of paradox because the mathematical
ideas can be directly accessed by the
conscious thinking so we would exist in
two kinds of world at the same time we
exist in this world
but somehow our minds have access to
this other dimension which I don't think
of it as think of it's not physical as
is perhaps not the right way of thinking
of it it comes out it's a different
concept you see most of the things in
the physical world don't seem to have
awareness and those things which do
somehow that you organized it correctly
and then you get the awareness coming
out of it that's the sort of view I had
I mean I think of them it's not right to
think of them a separate world so I
don't think of it in the way that a
dualist might that there's a separate
entity which is the mind or something
like that it comes out of the operation
of others is a world I mean I don't
think you'll get a scientist to say
anything more inflammatory than that in
the moment I really don't in that case
ladies and gentlemen would you join me
in thanking
for motivates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute's of
arts and ideas at IAI TV
you